it's my husband he's gone missing listen
I'm terribly worried it's just friends
never been gone this long before how
long has he been missing since the
funeral well I can start right away err
private investigator my profession is
very complicated okay it's new one guys
well that's a lot
you be people up and charge money yeah
sad isn't it how much would you charge
to be at my friend Janet what how much
you got Enki bucks that's good this
conversation is over the mob is trying
to spread its operation to Los Angeles
somehow my daughter amelia is involved
please find her I've seen this girl
what's in it for me oh we can do this
the easy way wow you're currently doing
it the easy way whatever happened to
offer me 20 bucks it's the recession
this is a high-profile case made the
newspapers
where is Amelia girls going on oh you
know is a guy hey I'm gonna kill us that
kind of crap hey can you behave like a
professional she's in danger man if you
do something about it she's dead she's
not catch oh why do you think everyone
involved with this case was dying this
is not you you're not a murderer just
kill three people I know but I'm singh
deep down look if you come in here you
beat up on me part of the job I accept
it but why did you do you pissed me off
before we go solving the crime a century
let's deal with the rotting corpse you
got planned March jacobina shopping is
your dentistry 2030 fellas [ __ ] buddy
Brett Hite reservation it's been
electric shaver for such hogwash law
wanted